[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview now a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the Daily Mirror Economist Susie
Boniface and the acting Deputy political
editor of the mail on Sunday Claire
Ellicott they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so let us see
what is on some of those front pages for
you now well the telegraph leads with
the international criminal court issuing
an arrest warrant for Russian President
Vladimir Putin in connection with
alleged war crimes in Ukraine
the mail claims that a planned five-week
strike by passport office staff could
delay a million applications
it's the same story for the Times
holidays hit as passport staff walk out
overpay
and the star invokes Cliff Richard
declaring we're not going on a summer
holiday
meanwhile the guardian has learned that
NHS doctors are being offered as much as
5 000 pounds in cash to recruit
colleagues into private hospitals
at the end of what it calls a week of
Madness the financial times reports that
460 billion dollars has been wiped off
the value of Bank stocks worldwide
that's around 377 billion pounds
the express has word of a planned Revolt
amongst pensioners if an increase to the
BBC license fee goes ahead
and the mirror is happy that people who
hunt animals abroad will now be banned
from importing them back into the UK as
trophies
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Susie
Boniface and Claire Ellicott excuse me
losing my voice there welcome to you
both let's start with the telegrapher
and their front page War crime arrest
warrant for Putin the President Putin
accused of abducting Ukrainian children
by the international criminal court
Susie
yeah if uh anybody out there is um a
student of the second world war you
might remember something called the
labens born experiment which was when
Nazis and the SS in particular
um stole Children looked a bit blonde
and blue-eyed and gave them to SS
families to raise they had pregnant
single unmarried mothers and put them in
homes and stole their children once they
were born and it was a way of aryanizing
um the people who in the countries that
they had occupied these were polish
children Danish children Norwegian
children who were raised in the wrong
place by the wrong people and who lost
their culture as a result and there's
still lots of impacts of the labensport
experiment across Europe today and we've
known for some time that something very
similar is happening in Ukraine now
under cover of saying that um he is
evacuating Russian children to safety
Vladimir Putin has signed into effect
laws which basically make it possible to
forcibly adopt
Russian parents to forcibly adopt
Ukrainian children
who are tricked or just flat stolen bust
out of occupied areas in eastern Ukraine
and sent to places in Russia often many
many many thousands of miles away from
their original home and with their
parents not knowing where they are and
without having given permission so this
is one of those things where we have
known this was happening it is a clear
sign of a genocide when it does happen
because it shows you're trying to
destroy an entire culture and a nation
um and it's it's about time frankly it's
well after time zelenski has been asking
for um the ICC to be taking action on
this for about the past year
um but it needed to be done and what it
means more than anything else it puts it
may never come to court over it but it
means that he's now banned from a
hundred countries worldwide and if he
sets foot in them then he could be
arrested and it what it really means is
that in the long term there is no way
out of this for him there is no way back
to sit at the United Nations table to go
in with the G20 he is going to be a
pariah and Russia is going to be a prior
State as long as he is at the head of
that table and that's what it means more
than anything else it's it's the
International Community saying there's
no way back for you you've gone too far
so this is highly significant isn't it
because he's only the third serving
president to be issued an ICC a arrest
Warren that's after Sudan's Omar
al-Bashir Mohammed Gaddafi Libya's late
dictator so I mean this is not something
that the international criminal court
um does a willy-nilly or frequently by
any means
yes there's a huge moral victory for
president zelenski of Ukraine and and
it's a really really positive move and
to to Clump down on some of the things
that Russia's doing but as Susie points
out it's also sadly largely symbolic
because there's not really going to be a
way that you're going to be able to get
Putin in front of that court and what it
does mean is that he won't be able to
visit any members who have signed up for
the ICC which means he can't go anywhere
in Europe and it's only really places
like China and Iran that he can visit
and um it also means that you know he's
going to be a pariah from from now on we
already know we've had terrible stories
about Ukrainian children being told
they're going on school trips and you
know planned holidays and then not
returning to their parents and um Russia
have been quite open about this so this
is this is what's interesting about this
that the ICC of homes and on this issue
because because the Russian and the
Russians have been quite open about this
procedure they've been saying that it's
a humanitarian rescue and and they've
not they've they've admitted that
they've taken these children away so
it's quite easy to pin on them in some
respects and this is the first time that
a Russian has been
um has been issued a permanent of Rest
In by the ICC since the Ukrainian War
Began so it's a huge move and I'm sure
it will be very positively received in
Ukraine uh Susie what what do you think
it means for any potential negotiations
because uh Xi Jinping the the China's
president is set to visit Moscow on
Monday to to talk about a ceasefire
well I suspect even without the ICC
intervention here president zielinski
when he meets she's in pain after the
trip to Moscow
um is would have made the return of it's
about 16 000 children they think they've
got definite evidence of 164 having been
taken but they think it's probably more
likely about 16 000. I'm sure zielinski
would have made that a condition of any
negotiation under in any circumstances
and the way the war has been going
um zielinski is pretty you know
confident I think of being able to push
Russia even back to the original
boundaries before they annexed Crimea so
that would mean that you know the
territories these children were taken
from which Putin disputes would just
would be indisputably Ukrainian after if
he was able to do that um and when
President XI makes those visits uh it's
going to be something that now he cannot
ignore it's not something that he can't
discuss this with Putin when they when
they sit down together and it may well
be the timing of this has been quite
well relevant that it's been done at a
certain time for a reason with the West
is very worried that President XI May in
some way arm Russia as things carry on
and progress and get worse and they want
to make it quite clear to president she
that actually there's a lot of stuff on
on his plate that he has some
responsibility for if he doesn't ask
Putin about these children if he doesn't
raise this issue if he doesn't answer
zelenski's questions about it then you
know she's position is not going to be
that of a peace broker and his position
would therefore be weakened so they're
kind of in a way I suppose it's
maneuvering China into having to be a
position of being a bit more reasonable
and a bit more sort of Center ground
about things than they have been so far
okay but do you think that the warrant
will make Putin less likely to um come
to the negotiating table do you think
that this has now changed the balance
because it's not giving him a way to to
climb down is it
well it's this this move has clearly
made um the Russia Furious must go
Furious about this and um they're
they're clearly angry so it has clearly
had some impact but I doubt whether it
will actually change anything materially
and I think Russia are in a in a bit of
a predicament at the moment and you're
at a kind of crucial point we're a year
into the invasion and um you are seeing
sides being taken you're seeing the West
increasingly arming Ukraine and this
visit from the president from Xi Jinping
of China is worrying because the one
thing that could really swing the
balance of the war in Russia's favor and
is China and um as we know China are
trying to occupy the they're trying to
enable negotiations under the guise of
you know a peace broker trying to
negotiate some sort of ceasefire the
Western made clear that they won't
accept
um any sort of deal that means that um
Keith have to accept some of the
um you know the bits that have already
been invaded of Ukraine that they have
to see those in any agreement and so
there is there is a real problem there
but I think Xi Jinping is due to speak
to and zelenski after speaking to Putin
and so we'll see what happens with that
but there's no doubt that it won't be it
won't be a deal that Ukraine um see is
in its favor we shall see that that'll
be an interesting meeting to keep across
um let's move to the mail Susie uh
domestic issues the looming passport
strike
yep so the males reporting that um
summer holidays are going to be at risk
because the PCS Union which has about a
thousand members in the 4 000 or so
people who work in the possible office
are going to be going out on strike in a
dispute over pain conditions uh for five
weeks um now I'm not quite sure how the
males done its maths here because they
calculate in the space of those five
weeks those people would normally be
expected to process a million passport
applications which is where they're
getting the um the claim that your
summer holidays are at risk from but of
course three and four of the PCS staff
are still three three and four so the
passport staff are still going to be
there
so there is still going to be some of
them processed and
um if we did a million passports every
five weeks that would mean we were doing
10 million passports a year and that
that would mean the entire population of
Britain was getting its passport renewed
every six years which doesn't six seven
years doesn't doesn't quite add up to me
I don't know where the maths are we
haven't seen the inside page yet if
there's any explanation about that or
justification for that figure but it
does definitely mean that there's going
to be some delays but of course our
lovely uh post-brexit blue passports are
printed in Poland uh by a company which
is mostly owned by the French so they're
pretty efficient uh compared to um you
know as if it was happening in the UK
the times are also pointing to that uh
million figure saying that a million
people could be affected Claire
yes and I think it's a particularly busy
time for processing passports which is
that's why it's a higher number than it
is for other months um it's a crucial
period where people look at their
passports they're planning their summer
holidays and um they they work out that
they need to get um they need to renew
and I think there's a suggestion at the
moment that it could be about 10 weeks
to renew your passport and that could be
longer than that and but either way
there's going to be major delays and I
think any family sort of planning a
holiday now after the years of the
pandemic and um strikes and everything
else I think there are strikes in
Heathrow Terminal Five as well that are
being that are being planned for the
Easter holidays and it's hard not to
feel Under Siege if you're a family and
the cost of everything's going up the
cost of the air travels going up
um I think it's a really difficult time
and I think you know families probably
do feel like it is a bit of a war on
summer holidays and um they're probably
not going to have much patience with it
yeah security guards are
could take part in a 10-day strike in
another disputer over a pay but um the
times is quoting a travel and personal
finance expert saying that unfortunately
it's highly unlikely that your travel
insurance will provide cover if you
don't have a valid passport when you're
due to travel so that's another woe for
um all those people hoping to go away
for their summer holiday they won't even
have any comeback Susie
well no but I mean if you didn't have
your passport organized in time that
would apply to to anybody I think I mean
the fact is that we're in a situation
where there's Perpetual strikes going on
in lots of different walks of life and
if you're not on strike in your own
industry then the industries you're
relying on for something are going to be
on strike or or you're gonna have other
problems to deal with with it and I
think most people appreciate that there
is a huge cost of living
uh crisis and that people need paying
more for that and I think they also
appreciate that there's been you know 10
more than 10 years 13 years of constant
cutbacks which have just meant that the
passport office and the Border agency in
particular have lost a lot of staff and
had a loss of changes to their working
conditions over the past few years which
they've been asked to do more and more
and more and are getting paid
effectively less and less for it and so
they've got every right to go out on
strike and if that disrupts people that
is sort of the point of a strike isn't
it it's you're not supposed to be able
to go out and strike it doesn't affect
anybody that that wouldn't be a strike
and the answer to this is to do what the
government has finally as far as some of
the NHS staff are concerned got round to
realizing which is you get around the
table and negotiate and you find a
middle ground everyone can live with the
way that the government has handled the
all the industrial action in the public
sector up till now which is just to
ignore it and say it'll go away if we
just you know that no one will like this
it'll just piss everybody off no one's
going to be on the side of the strikers
that hasn't worked out especially as far
as the NHS is concerned it's not working
out as far as the teachers are concerned
and the best thing to do really was to
was to settle a bit early and negotiate
a bit earlier because all that happened
with the strikes is get more and more
delays and waiting this to grow Susie
and uh Claire thank you for the moment
we'll apologize for your colorful
language there um Susie I'm sure you
won't do it again
coming up no longer a matter of Pride
we'll tell you about a new development
in the laws around trophy hunting when
we come back
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview with me still Susie Boniface and
Claire Ellicott let us take a look at
the mirror on this front page story The
Mirror claiming victory in a campaign
that they've been running and this is
MP's likely to vote on a ban the
importation of animal body parts that
people that pay to go hunting and they
bring them back as as trophies uh Claire
take us into this story
well who can forget the case of Cecil
the lion he was shot a few years ago and
I think a businessman paid 35
000 pounds to shoot him in Zimbabwe
um it was it it was a case that caused
loads of horror people were Furious
about it and um eventually very many
years later there's this um trophy
hunting band so this is a ban on
importing the trophies the heads the
horns and the tales of animals who've
been killed in places like big Safari
parks in Africa and bringing them back
to the UK and what's interesting about
this is it wasn't a government bill even
the government have said that they would
ban it in the past it's a private
member's Bill brought forward by a bench
NP and it's it's a seismic move and um
it's got through the House of Commons
and despite a number of MPS subjecting
to it and it has now reached the House
of Lords and it should become law and
it's a huge victory for animal rights
and animal people who are pro animal
rights and the vast majority of the
public I think are probably on site with
this there are some people who argue
that trophy hunting is good for
conservation because people pay large
amounts of money and that enables more
work to be done to preserve the habitats
of these animals but the vast majority
of the public are really in favor of
something like this and I think it was a
huge day when this went through in the
comments today and a lot of ministers
were very were sort of very tearful as
it as it went through um on both sides
of the house so a big day for animal
rights I think Susie what do you think
of the argument that it is good for
conservation actually it's it's a lot of
income that these various countries are
going to lose out on which would
actually help them keep many of the
species alive and thriving
really had when you actually on the
geometers I've been reporting on various
poaching and other issues that they have
in some of these game reserves
um some big game Hunters have funded
anti-poaching patrols for example but
you know if you had a thriving tourism
industry without big game hunting then
that lion which perhaps it's it's death
might raise 50 000 pounds you know how
much of that is going to the local
community how much of it's actually
going to a white businessman who is
selling the the trip in the first place
how much of it is being used to export
stuff out of the country how much was
actually going to the guys at the bottom
of the pile and if you didn't have that
if that businessman wasn't spending 50
Grand to shoot the lion then how men
much more money could you make out of
attracting multiple tourists to come and
see that same lion you know in situ or
to support them there in the environment
um it doesn't really add up the
conservation argument sometimes
um they're ways of doing it and there
are ways of making sure the pop is
healthy for uh for wild animals and what
you should be doing with you know any
kind of hunting is ensuring that the
ones that you hunt are
the older Lions who have for example in
the older wild animals who have had done
their breeding who have raised their
families and who are now getting sick
and are getting a bit older but
unfortunately those are not the ones
that people are interested in killing
it's just flat and it says here in this
mirror story and it's a campaign that
the papers run for many years uh and
it's you know we we win our campaigns
alarmingly often really because we
shouldn't have to campaign on this stuff
it should be clear and obvious you'd
have thought
how people could be this Psychopathic we
must want to go and kill we must leave
it there Susie I'm afraid but you'll
have a chance to say much much more in
the next hour Susie and Claire for the
moment